ça s'est passé je n'ai pas réalisé que
j'étais une femme battue dans le
documentaire intitulé sortir de l'ombre
christiane m&c dévoile au grand jour son
histoire le film a été comme une
thérapie et le film a permis d'affronter
mes démons tout ce qui était lié à la
violence conjugale
et puis tout ce qui tournait autour
l'immigration le mariage 8 le meilleur
le pôle bi le meilleur poulain le pipeau
la faim ni en côte d'ivoire
christiane et son mari de l'époque sont
arrivés au canada il ya douze ans
rapidement le quotidien de cette femme
souriante a viré au cauchemar
c'était quelqu'un qui était viola mais
arrivé ici l'immigration ici a décuplé
cette violence là je vais tirer en
hausse est assez lent j'ai pas besoin de
subir ça plusieurs femmes d'origine
africaine se sont livrés à la caméra
pour sortir de l'ombre
un film sur la violence conjugale mais
aussi sur les difficultés de
l'intégration des immigrants venus
d'afrique dont aïssata cissé
quand je pense à tout ce que ma main a
traversé je veux que ça fasse réagir et
puis je m'attends pas forcément à des
commentaires positifs
je suis sûr qu'on va se faire taper
dessus en tant que femme d'avoir osé
prendre la parole
une adaptation s'impose on n'a pas de
choix le tour de force de ce film est
aussi de montrer plusieurs hommes qui
ont à coeur l'égalité et qui se posent à
la violence faite aux femmes
moi j'estime qu'un couple de la
complémentarité chacun a son point de
vue a donné puis on peut pas trouver de
solution si on se met à parler un peu
comme si c'est deux camps différents
pour former une famille ça prend tous
les gens ça prend les enfants ça prend
les grands quand on est en afrique on a
l'habitude de l'outil fameux tube doit
se tenir dans marit le film sortir de
l'ombre ne laissera personne indifférent
et il donne la parole à des gens qu'ils
ont rarement christianisme et et aïssata
cissé espère que leur message d'espoir
sera entendu 8 c'est difficile on peut
s'en sortir c'est possible je suis la
preuve vivante qu'on peut s'en sortir et
qu'on peut y arriver ça sera pas
toujours facile mais il faut juste
mettre un pied devant l'autre
pourquoi est ce que j'ai fait le choix
qui m'a amené à être aujourd'hui ici ici
ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal